welcome to the iced coffee hour i'm
jason oppenheim and so far this podcast
has made 1.8 million dollars
oh wow
way off geez i wish all right fine gosh
i'm going to be getting some revenue cut
with that you're the highest guest so
far people have ranged anywhere from
like well i know what you do on your
other [ __ ] so
oh my gosh uh so i'll tell you that
totally 180 000 okay oh
more realistic all right so the lifetime
revenue of this 146 000 honestly pretty
close that's enough is it worth your
time graham yes all right because we
have sponsors
so this is just the adventure you get
free you do this for free iced coffee
well i have my own iced coffee now
bankroll coffee oh that's right yeah
yeah i gotta give you some coffee all
right you can actually put it in the
office i should it shouldn't be drinking
this earth cafe then
that dirt that nasty stuff you have oat
milk then i'll do it we do actually
well thank you thank you so much for
coming on today i really appreciate this
oh my pleasure i think it's come full
circle because i've been with the
oppenheim group since 2015 when you
first opened up the office in west
hollywood had no idea that anything
would happen with a show that was never
the intention it was just pure real
estate what show
selling sunset oh that's right we gotta
we gotta introduce that so uh yeah i
think a few years ago we would have
introduced this entirely differently but
uh now you get this this hit show on
netflix
five seasons right yeah season five
comes out in a couple months
wow i gotta say so admittedly i do know
what show just doing it for the audience
my girlfriend is a fan of the show
so
definitely familiar with it but i heard
that it was such a hit show that now
there's a spin-off is that true
yeah selling the oc about my newport
beach office um just started filming a
couple weeks ago i know and hopefully
hopefully a vegas show because i think
i'm going to open up a vegas office soon
yeah if we could talk i've been so
excited about that you don't you don't
know about this actually no i didn't
know about that i've been good i haven't
signed the lease yet so i can't say
where but
um
should we should we wait to talk about
this
no i don't care okay i'll probably send
it in the next week or so i've been
really looking forward to it i've not
told a single person this entire time
which is hard for me to keep a secret
like this but i've been so excited to be
able to go back into the office and get
my real estate license so i'm gonna do
that this year yeah
yeah we're going to get graham out of
youtube back to real estate
so when i buy a house you're going to i
could represent you're going to wrap me
up and you're going to give me like a
whole commission right don't get carried
away
sorry i still gotta get my commission
but yeah the show is such a success but
tell us from the very beginning how you
got involved in real estate because you
were a lawyer before
got into real estate you were working uh
as an assistant right for the first two
no i worked as a real estate agent for
joyce ray's office yeah um
and
yeah i i was a lawyer for many years i
enjoyed it ish you know i mean as much
as i think you can at a major law firm
but i'd always loved real estate so
after traveling for a while after i left
law i came back to real estate
um yeah tough couple first years you
know like making
50 grand a year you know not much for
los angeles
uh and then you know things and i worked
with stacy and joyce and who you know
and and then i worked across the hall
from you
yeah and you know we were both graham
was hustling leases and i was hustling
everything i could too so you know it
was a it was a fun but you know not
exactly glamorous first couple years you
were telling me too that you left law
and i i think you had seen a survey or
something that said it was the most
unhappy career or something like that
right yeah a real estate agent was was
right number one the happiest career so
i went from the least happy to the most
happy which is i mean i wouldn't say
that i was miserable as a lawyer i think
most
lawyers are i think i i was okay i was
on a great case i had great uh
colleagues
but i mean i'm so much happier now so
just to get the timeline right you were
working so after you stopped being laura
you went into real estate you're working
across the hall from graham and then
after that is that when you decided to
start the oppenheim group yeah it took
i think i was there maybe like three and
a half years at coldwell banker
and then i decided to start the
oppenheim group and what did you because
i'm assuming you brought graham along
with you uh at some point yeah i think
you were my first hire right and so what
did you see in graham at that time
working with him in coldwell baker
coldwell banker that gave you the idea
you know this kid working leases why
should i bring him on with me like what
did you see in that well
first of all graham and i were friends
just from working so close together and
two he was just like a
a hustler for sure i mean he really
really put in the hours and you know you
can just tell when someone's got that
energy and that ambition and motivation
and graham had that and it was just you
know we just got along so it was like it
was an obvious first hire for me yeah i
remember you in in the office jason so
jason got this little it was basically a
closet it was it was it was actually
well before that i was in stacy's office
yeah and with like a little desk in the
corner right then i ended up getting my
own little closet right next to you yeah
right and that's where we started
interacting it was a closet like i
guarantee your closet is bigger than
jason's office was at the time yeah it
was smaller than than this oh yeah way
smaller yeah it's like halfway i also
started in the closet
actually the laundry the laundry room
yeah
okay yeah we needed a space for alex to
edit videos and we're like what's the
one room we don't use at all in the
laundry room so and it was big laundry
room was actually probably the size of
your office so you and i just started in
the states yeah because because jack was
in here and but now that he has his own
place you know i can work right there
you know so it works out but yeah
definitely but you decked out that
office i mean relatively i put like
hardwood hardwood uh flooring on the
ceiling and the
floor ended up backfiring because it was
like it was so noisy in there because it
was like this little box yeah and when i
would talk it would ricochet off so it
wasn't such a good idea but no it was a
terrible idea because everyone could
hear you on the phone usually yelling
and you would be on hold with customer
service and you would have he would he
would have these outbursts he wouldn't
hear him at all and he would leave his
door open and he would say you will not
put me on hold do not put me on he gets
put on oh i would have i had a attitude
back people on the phone was back then i
don't even know i mean i was i didn't
have an assistant back then so i was
doing all the little myself and i get
annoyed as well yeah so but i remember
because i was working with this those
were clients probably yeah do not put me
on all but this other agent uh his name
is vigili would have to go over and shut
the door because he was on the phone
closing because it was so loud with the
with the hardwood ceilings and literally
our
office was like three three feet from
each other so yeah so so you did the two
years there and how much did you make
this two years total over the two years
like 100 grand yeah like 50 grand a year
i mean it was a rough
couple years because i was used to
making you know six figures as a lawyer
um so you took a pay cut as a oh huge
yeah because i mean i was i think the
law was paying you know two to three
hundred when i left probably 300 by the
time i left
and then when i started back i was you
know living in a i mean i was living in
a one bedroom apartment with my buddy
alex swapping back between the couch and
the bed because you know like one month
on the couch one month in the bed so it
was not
by any means glamorous driving my my
grandfather's like 700 dollar i think i
paid 700 for it and i think i sold it
for 600 so i didn't depreciate okay
that's good but yeah i mean it wasn't
you know i wasn't on the high life like
i was as a lawyer but i was happy
because you know i had no expectations i
didn't have
any real responsibilities uh so you know
it was fun and i you know i was i was
playing the long game which anyone
should getting into real estate you
shouldn't focus on your first few years
what were your savings like when you
left did you have like about 110 000
saved up when i left and then i traveled
the world for three years spent all of
it plus another 40 grand on credit cards
no
so i was yeah i was hurting financially
when i came back
yeah and
and i don't we
i think my dad had to wire money into my
bank account so i could get a an
apartment at 1400 a month with my friend
and i'd give it back to him after
after we got the apartment because i had
no job and no money so you couldn't even
get an apartment your parents think of
you leaving oh they were supportive
really yeah they've never they've always
been supportive of my friends thought i
was stupid
mostly but my parents were super
supportive okay and then after your two
years in real estate what made you want
to open up the opponent well
i think i had my third year i was i was
getting more successful okay oh you know
at joyce's office and then no and
actually i think i spent four years with
joyce my third year was a little more
successful my fourth year was pretty
damn successful
and that's when i thought you know i've
always just wanted to work for myself i
always wanted to be an entrepreneur
i was super nervous about going on my
own i thought i was going to lose at
least 50 of my business you know the big
brokerages always tell you it's all
about the brokerage and you've got to
like
you know stay with them and they're
going to get your ass handed to you if
you go on your own yeah and but back
then there weren't that many boutique
brokerages you know i think the agency
had come out but it wasn't like this
free-for-all like it is now with all
these different brokerages
uh and i just worked out of my my house
you know i had this small house i had a
second bedroom i just worked out of the
second bedroom
i hired an assistant i mean things were
pretty slow
the first year decided to get an office
you know which is the the current office
and then you yeah then you just like you
were doing well up until the point where
you got an office yeah yeah i think i
had done like 300 my my third year in
700 my fourth year and that's a lot of
money to make four years in real estate
yeah i was doing pretty well the third
and fourth and that's when i decided to
to go on my own yeah how did you do that
well
most people are in real estate for 20
years and they're never making 700 yeah
i was i mean you remember i mean i was
just working i was grinding back then i
was working 10 15 hour days i loved it i
was super ambitious i you know i was
scared you know i mean like i had left a
a successful career and i wanted to be
successful again so i just had every
motivation i was just hustling oh my god
i was hustling i wish i still had all
that hustle but before we go to that i
want to thank our sponsors storyblocks
graham i don't have time to record this
right now i have so much editing to do
are you using storyblocks no why trust
me once you use storyblocks you're gonna
have all the time in the world to get
back to work storyblocks is a
subscription service that gives you
instant access to millions of high
quality royalty-free hd and 4k footage
templates images sound effects you name
it yeah finding the right piece of
b-roll is crucial and finding something
like this really cute kitten would have
taken me hours before but with story
blocks saved me the time and it was
right there i can't tell you how many
hours i've spent looking for the right
images or sound effects to use on my
edits but with story blocks it saves me
so much time oh bailey's shooting on the
wire whether you're part of a large
media company or just trying to
jumpstart your creative vision
storyblocks is right for you and with
their flexible and scalable subscription
plans you can start creating content
with the tools that you need without
having to worry about the budget take it
from us we've been using storyblocks now
for well over a year and when they
reached out we're really happy to have
them as a sponsor creative burnout is a
real thing and creative inspiration
doesn't have to be so taxing and you
know i hate taxes so learn more about
how you can take your editing to the
next level by visiting storyblocks.com
ich that's storyblocks.com ich thank you
so much for sponsoring this
i'll get it right alex thank you so much
storyblocks and back to the pod no i'm
supposed to say back to the podcast
jacks thing all right back to the
podcast do you find that that goes away
after a certain age or like is it a
dollar amount or is it an age where you
start to want to like not work so hard
you know i think
i think i i works much smarter now you
know i i delegate a lot more
back then i wasn't comfortable spending
any money on an assistant now i delegate
a lot so i'm a much smarter worker you
know i focus on the more high level
things but back then
and i think that's where you learn i was
just doing every little thing myself uh
and and i was
i still am but just overly meticulous
and ocd about everything everything had
to be perfect yeah i would re-read i
didn't i didn't probably have a single
spelling mistake in a single email for
like the first four years of my career
maybe five now i mean you'll be lucky if
i capitalize anything
wow
i kind of see a little bit of of
parallels between the work ethic between
you two and i could see why you guys got
along and why you hired graham yeah we
were super similar you know i mean you
are still grinding yourself too but we
were probably the two hardest workers in
the office i would say
yeah i would always stay in the latest i
would you and usually for for those
first few years i wouldn't leave until
usually like 1am i loved i loved working
late that was my thing yeah it was just
it was oftentimes just the two of us in
the office yeah but like after 9pm is
just something about it where there's no
one else there there's no traffic in
front of the in front of the office and
it's just peaceful and like you could
get anything done and there's not a rush
i really like that and i also like in
real estate that you can work 15 hours a
day i mean there's always i mean the
first couple of years i don't have much
going i don't know i don't think i did a
deal for the almost the first year i
think my i started in
january of 2010 i think my first deal
was october of 2010. so i mean you know
10 months of studying street maps and i
remember i would print out every single
contract uh there was and just read it
and highlight it and memorize every
single contract so if a client ever
asked me a question i had the answer
yeah i mean it was very tedious menial
and then going to every open house and
broke her up and trying to kind of learn
about you know what a house is worth and
you know finishes fixtures i mean the
whole thing there's so much to learn
that's why i love real estate what was
the most challenging part of that was it
the contracts or was it no no that stuff
was always i was getting clients i mean
for me
i as an attorney and just someone who's
whose mind you know enjoys
uh contracts and negotiations i love all
the detail so for me it was it was the
clients that was probably the hardest
thing
did you ever set any goals when you
first started your own business like oh
i know i'm successful when i hit oh yeah
i remember it's funny because i'm when i
was in vegas with with the guy who i set
my goal with and we wanted to make ten
thousand dollars a month
that was our ultimate goal is if we can
we figured if we could be making ten
thousand dollars a month and we're
living the high life and you know we
could do whatever we want which is
amusing because i mean the more you make
the more you know you need and the more
you get tied down and my costs right now
are insane
um but that was the goal the goal was
ten thousand dollars a month yeah so
when you made that seven hundred
thousand dollar a year four years in did
you save that were you investing it or
what were you doing with that money well
i was saving to buy a hat my first house
so i think
in two yeah in 2013 i bought my first
house for like 1.3 million yeah on
londonderry still have it that was an
incredible buy by the way yeah
incredible yeah it was great essentially
it's a triplex basically well then i
spent like 1.2 million remodeling it so
i'm really into it like two five but
yeah that thing was awesome what's it
worth now probably four i'd say and so
uh i would expect more than that no i
think just four yeah because it's it's
like 3 000 square feet total and maybe
it's worth like four who cares i'm never
selling yeah i have a 30-year loan on
that thing i'm just never selling it
yeah it's like my little do you
currently live there no no i rent it out
oh okay okay so yeah so you're saving up
to buy that that property and then when
did you decide to open up the office
that was like almost right across the
street from that yeah so the office was
about a hundred feet 200 feet from from
my house
um
early
i think i
uh late 2014 i signed the lease and i
think i opened like january 2015. yeah
yeah how'd you do the math on that to
make sure you weren't going to lose
money oh it's going from nothing to 10
000 a month it was
i don't do that
on business decisions which is
served me well but i wouldn't recommend
it to you know to anyone
but i always just do what i think is
going to be fun and exciting and i
always just like have this belief it's
going to work out same with vegas this
vegas office i'm planning on spending
like 1.5 million to build it out and you
know hundreds of thousands of dollars a
month in rent
and it it makes zero
business sense what i'm doing zero
um
but you know every other business
decision has worked out i've just done
it the way i want to do it and just
believe that that it'll work out yeah so
when doing the oppenheim group how did
you pick the first few agents who were
in the office friends yeah just chose my
friends yeah i mean for me
what's important is and i've always
gone about it this way which is why we
still have you know the same 15 people
at the oppenheim group
um i've just always wanted to enjoy what
i'm doing and be happy you know and i
don't want i'm very particular about
people so i just want people that i
enjoy working with you know enjoy going
to lunch with whatever i like that
environment so it's not worth it for me
to be hiring people that i don't i don't
see myself like becoming a good friend
with sure
have you had any experiences where
you've hired someone though and it
turned out to be different than what you
expected it didn't work out couple times
i've let a couple people go um just
because i just you know i didn't get the
feeling that i wanted okay
yeah and how are you finding people now
people reach out every day i mean we're
not really expanding i mean in vegas
i'll have to hire a bunch of people
uh orange county
um
i you know i didn't really reach out to
people they people reached out to me and
i just selected those people i thought i
would like so why vegas i know you'd say
because you have a feeling but there's
got to be a more strategic reason well
okay one it's it's cause there's a few
reasons yeah yeah you'll be my first
time for the second time that would be
great
i can get back my little boss oh yeah so
i took yeah so that was from the
oppenheim group uh i forgot what it was
la office yeah you were moving this what
was it saying ipads yeah in the window
with our listing with our little you
know photos of our listings why'd you
move them out i forget i forget what the
reason why you took them
you just took them no one morning
to put a tv in the window oh that was it
yeah and you said then you took them
yeah oh cool i'll get them back
those are yours those are yours but uh
so why vegas though so okay one it's
close so i can be here i can be here
door-to-door two hours
um to the real estate market in vegas
the luxury market is is going very well
i mean you're seeing uh exponential
growth uh three there's a tremendous
confluence from los angeles to las vegas
because a ton of people from california
are moving to las vegas
so it's kind of a natural
progression for me
um it's west coast you know so kind of
building the brand slowly on this side
of the of the country
and also uh i like vegas you know i like
coming out here there's great
restaurants i can stay at the encore and
stuff so it's nice and there's a lot of
reasons and then my friends are out here
and then alex and alice and matt will
help me build up the office it's so
close
i found an insane spot so i'm really
happy with that that's cool are you
worried about the real estate market
going down i think a lot of people are
concerned about housing values
yeah but the real estate brokerage model
doesn't really care so much about
prices as much as it does about volume
so i think we're going to still see a
lot of volume i still think we'll see a
lot of
purchases and sales i think there's a
lot
of
luxury land coming on the market a lot
of luxury building now unfortunately a
lot of it's like toll brothers and
things like that they don't have agents
but i think the market in vegas is
poised for you know some some very good
years ahead of it but first i'd like to
thank our sponsor vinovus
wait a second i don't know how to invest
graham quit whining
wine that's it what's it wine we say
this all the time but one of the best
ways to build your wealth is
diversifying your assets and since wine
has a very low correlation to the stock
market it's perfect in the first quarter
of 2020 the dow in the s p dropped a
whole 22 percent and where did that
leave wine up 1.1 percent and vinovest
is the best and easiest place to invest
in wine they inspect every bottle for
authenticity store them in a
climate-controlled room and monitor them
24 7. so what costs more a new bottle of
wine or an old one an old one man it's
simple economics don't patronize me and
since every wine is made with a limited
supply as bottles are consumed it makes
it more scarce and therefore more
valuable with vinovest being so easy to
use there's no reason not to invest in
combat inflation so guys check out
vinovest using the link in the
description down below today again guys
that's veenovest the link is down below
in the description and start
diversifying your assets today and with
that jack
do you think it's possible for it
because in la we don't have like a toll
brothers builder it's not like they
could buy big trucks of land it's it's
here there's land is everywhere so if a
builder buys like 20 30 acres they could
build all these properties on it makes
sense at scale but do you think that
model would allow for like an individual
to go and be like i'm gonna build this
house and sell it here
no
i don't think there's a great model for
individual building here unless unless
that person is has economies of scale so
i think by definition if you're just
building one house you don't yeah
uh or maybe if you're building like a 20
million dollar house you know so you
could do everything very custom but
someone coming in and just you know
remodeling a house and flipping it
doesn't make sense here yeah um yeah
because
or somebody coming in and building a 5
million house and selling it doesn't
make sense you can't compete with the
economies of scale the big building yes
so where is your expectation for the
real estate market over 2022
probably i'm up a little bit but
relatively flat you know i think
interest rate increases will probably
put a damper on this you know kind of
extreme growth that we're seeing
um and i don't think we're going to see
a ton of sales honestly i think that
there's a you know supply problem right
now and i think that as interest rates
go up there's not going to be a lot of
people wanting to sell i mean if you
have a 2.8 percent rate and interest
rates are now at four and a half percent
why would you sell get rid of and lose
your great loan to go get a four and a
half percent loan so i think you're
gonna see
that also keep prices up too because it
just won't be a lot of supply but you
know for me unfortunately i don't see a
ton of volume moving forward in the next
couple years are you ever worried it's
going to get to a point where prices are
just so high that buyers are thinking
you know what i'm just going to wait it
out wait it out see what happens things
it depends on what market you're talking
about you know maybe in the one and two
million dollar price point you'll see
some of that but i think the wealthy are
not you know concerned about
waiting i think if they want a house
whether it's five million or six and a
half million they're gonna buy
you know i i think that if you're
on an on a fixed income and you're
trying to buy your first house and
things have gone up you know like they
have like 30
you're gonna see some people waiting on
the sideline but
i'll be honest i've been hearing about
people complaining about housing prices
since i got into real estate you know 12
years ago
and i'd say it's been going up for 12
years since a week i wonder what would
have happened if cova didn't happen
because the market was
when did they raise rates was it 2018.
yup
what let's tilt it down oh what happened
to that it probably just dropped okay so
you own a lot of real estate too could
you tell us about what you've bought
yeah so i buy luxury
residential real estate in los angeles
stuff that i love that i want to live in
but it ends up that i don't live in them
that long and i rent them out but i like
uh i like luxury rentals because you can
get you know there's a lot of wealthy
people that want to rent nice properties
in la and i do my houses really nice so
i have like kind of like a niche
for people that really want you know
something nice because a lot of rentals
aren't you know exquisitely furnished in
artwork and all that stuff
um and i just yeah so i rent out several
homes uh and i'll maybe i'll live in one
here and there but it's kind of hard
because they rent out for so much and i
don't want to lose that income so i end
up renting in like smaller places yeah
so when you say luxury homes here
what what are we five to ten million uh
value and then rental you know
30 to 60 000 a month
that's
that's insane
yeah who would pay for that i just
rented a house last week for 65 000 a
month and that's short-term rental but
there's a lot of people
coming in uh i mean i've got
several rentals all in that price point
there's just a lot of money and a lot of
people don't want to buy yet they just
want to rent or they don't know what
they're doing for a year or two
so they're just coming in rent and then
if you have that product if you have
like a very nice luxurious house with a
view
you know you know exquisitely furnished
then there's really not much competition
you know you can charge what you want
wow see my thought is if they don't know
what to do for a year or two
they would be
maybe maybe we think a little different
yeah my thought is i would they would
live somewhere where they could
use that money but i guess if they
already i think you're spending 65k you
don't care yeah you don't have fun they
want to enjoy their year or two in los
angeles it's a different market and the
idea of trying to save 10 or 20 grand a
month for them it doesn't really matter
i'd say above 20 grand a month people
don't care about budgeting not to that
extent of like well we could be better
putting this towards our down payment in
the future to them it's like it's a drop
in the bucket it really is yeah and you
know often times it's like two guys that
will rent a house and they're so they're
each paying you know 20 grand a month
and which is far more reasonable
um and then they get you know a 40 000 a
month house and it's big enough for two
people yeah so that's what happens a lot
but who are these these clients that
you're working with and have you noticed
a trend with your clients because ryan
surhan was mentioning that his wealthier
clients have been getting younger and
younger so they're no longer these like
60 year old people they're all in like
their 30s now their 40s well in the
hollywood hills it's never been
a 60 year old demographic it's always
been the 25 to 40. and it still is um it
still is so i wouldn't say there's been
much change i mean you do notice money
coming from different areas you know you
see a lot of crypto money now
um youtube money you see as well
uh so you know you'll see it coming from
different areas like but you don't
the hollywood hills was never about like
some seven year old guy that made his
money in oil and gas you know it was
always the the young kind of youtube
star or whatever yeah
maybe an actor but they don't usually
spend that much how many crypto people
have you worked with
how does that come out do they do they
just tell you like hey i just made a
whole bunch of money in bitcoin
yeah i mean because i i'll need to
qualify yeah hey do you take crypto for
this house i've never sold in crypto but
definitely actually i would say
i'm i'm certain that one of my tenants
uh has made money in crypto i think
another one of my tenants has
um so i mean it's certainly out there i
just
uh i'm i've got a client looking to buy
up to 10 million in las vegas crypto
money so i mean it's definitely you know
basically do you know what crypto he's
bitcoin bitcoin in fact i think most of
them that i'm talking that i i'm working
with are bitcoin okay so you've yet to
represent someone like dogecoin or i
have a coach
i have a friend
i'm leasing her house and she has a lot
of money in dogecoin although i don't
think she's done exceptionally well yeah
let's see i told her to get out she
bought in right when snl was
graham tell him your return on your
current return on doge oh
well okay so well the first story is
that uh when we first started this
podcast jack told me to invest a
thousand dollars in dogecoin and it was
a fraction of a penny he said just buy
it it's just gonna it's gonna be good
content so i bought it on robinhood and
uh i thought it was stupid and i sold it
at the peak it would have been worth
about 160 grand from a one thousand
dollar investment so it would have made
more money
everyone has a story about like my
brother bought bitcoin when it was like
you know 12 dollars a coin
but
nobody
i mean he says oh if i just hold on to
it but bro you would have sold it 50
times before it ever got to you know 50
thousand dollars that's true graham
would have sold it if he made it
yeah graham would have sold it a hundred
times before i got to
that i probably would have sold it when
i hit 5k because i'd be like that's
that's a 500 exactly like it's so you
know all those people that talk about
that i mean
they never would have held it until it
got that high so what are your thoughts
on crypto
oh i have a lot only not because no i
don't own any um
eric's been selling by the way for a
very long time i think crypto is
probably the future i mean i do think
that over the long term it's probably an
excellent investment although i
think that it might be inflated now so
i'm just too concerned to get in now i
think
and i'm not i'm not really good at
owning anything that i can track on a
day-to-day basis like drives me crazy
i'm always i'll be looking it up like
every two hours so i wouldn't i don't
think i'd enjoy having a substantial
stake in that crypto that said i do
believe that you know in 10 years i will
have wish i bought crypto but i don't
know if i
would be happy in a year from now or six
months from now
i think you should take a million just a
million bucks buy bitcoin or just 50 50
bitcoin ethereum if there's if there's a
big crash i might jump in but there
might not be a question just like you
said it's kind of inflated people are
saying the same about the housing market
and here you are be like there's a
couple reasons why i first of all you
can't really leverage crypto the way you
can leverage a house i mean if i could
borrow
you know five million dollars at 2.7
and buy crypto with it and hold crypto
for 30 years on that 30-year loan i
would do it but that doesn't exist yeah
but the leverage
if you think of the leverage and you
think you know the housing market went
up let's just say on an average year
let's say even five percent so you're
making it like a 20 return on your money
but when you look at bitcoin you could
be doing fifty percent annually forty
percent not to say that that'll happen
well in real estate i think you're
making twenty percent on your cash just
from
your average infl uh average increase
plus you're making rent so i think you
know you i could probably make 10
on day one on my cash on rent so it's
really 30
uh i don't think you're gonna you know
what
you know what bitcoin would have to be
for me to if i put a million dollars in
bitcoin and it and i made 30 for the
next 10 years
bitcoin would have to be at like
a million
or something or over a million i mean i
don't know my math isn't that good but
so no i don't i think i could make more
money in real estate we could use this
clip when it hits a million
i mean who knows i've spoken with some
people who are really into bitcoin like
uh you know like i'm i'm i'm losing
track of my 500 nine figures yeah like
nine figures in in bitcoin who are
convinced it'll hit a million dollars
like can i
yeah um because there are people that
are convinced it'll go down you know to
whatever
uh i don't think anyone knows anything
about the crypto market you know i think
it's just
way too much speculation right now a ton
of
um people leveraging
and i think that's really dangerous so i
think there's gonna be a lot of
regulatory um
uh
things going on in the next couple years
that will probably have an effect on the
market but i mean to pretend that you
know what's going to happen to
cryptocurrencies laughable i mean i
can't even
understand what's going to happen in the
real estate market and i think there's
way more fluctuation
in crypto got it so yeah yeah so um
you're in the luxury real estate market
ask me a question about
vintage football cards or real estate
what about the luxury
uh
metaverse real estate market oh yeah
what are your thoughts on the meta
version so yeah interesting question too
um
i think that that's
also i think maybe partially inflated
right now
but i think over the long run i think
that metaverse land is probably an
unbelievably awesome investment i mean
in the future i don't think there's any
question that in 20 years we're all
going to be in the metaverse i mean no
one's going to be working because
there's probably not any jobs because
we're all going to be automated except
luxury real estate
but honestly though i mean 80 of our
workforce in 20 years will be
they'll be sitting at home in the
metaverse um
plus when you introduce like porn into
the metaverse i'm just being honest yeah
then everyone's going to be staying at
home
so i think the future
is probably a lot of people staying at
home you know
it's it's too bad somebody's watching it
probably doing it in the middle every
time it's you know you have to think too
i was i got this idea like because we
were talking about the they sold a
virtual yacht for like nine hundred
thousand surprises right and i'm
thinking imagine that person who bought
that yacht could rent it out you can't
right a lot of people are renting
only people who could afford to pay the
50 grand can network with other people
who are willing to pay the 50 grand
imagine the networking that you could do
on a year it's like owning a board ape
right they have that networking but you
know what i'm mad about did you see the
qual like the resolution that's terrible
okay but it's all about it's all about
10 years from now but i could pay a
developer 900 grand and be like hey
develop me a better yacht i could
chill they spent i think about 150 or
250 000 uh building that yacht app i
thought
yeah so it's a lot of work
and then but then they you know they
sold it for way more
listen i think that it's unquestionable
that land in the metaverse is going to
be a tremendously valuable investment
the problem is you don't know what
metaverse yeah facebook's coming out
with one
others will so if you knew like
decentraland was the metaverse it was
going to be huge
but it's not going to be huge until it's
three-dimensional until you're aware and
nobody wants to put on a 10-pound oculus
so
in 10 years from now you'll probably
have a contact lens you'll put that in
and you'll be seeing you know a
three-dimensional metaverse and then
like i said i hate to be like you know
uh
overly honest about this but i do
believe that once porn gets introduced
it's gonna yeah you're gonna see a lot
of guys staying at home you know because
it's gonna be the most vivid like sexual
experience for people and i'm i'm
actually concerned
because i think
yeah because you don't you're not going
to need the other thing too is it's
going to affect real estate these
glasses yeah these contact lenses you're
not going to need a 5 million house with
a view because everyone's going to have
that you're going to
wake up in the meadow yeah you're going
to be in the metaverse probably 10 hours
a day you're just going to probably you
know use the restroom and eat and then
sleep outside the metaverse so i think
you'll be that's why i think land in the
metaverse is something you think it's
worth it to go in that direction though
like as a society
i think it's extremely concerning from a
societal perspective but that said it's
going to happen
we're going to be i think there's going
to be a tremendous loss of purpose
uh in 10 20 years i think you're going
to see kids i mean i think that our our
um the number of people having kids is
going to reduce dramatic to a very
concerning level
i think relationships will suffer i mean
i think that when you can be you know in
the metaverse having relationships that
real relationships will probably suffer
tremendously
um i think a lot of things are going to
suffer i mean i think you think
instagram is bad i mean it's nothing
compared to where people are going to be
in 20 years
yeah well you say instagram i think tick
tock because if we're talking about like
whatever i'm just saying like yeah
people are concerned that people are
spending too much time on tick tock and
instagram
when there's three dimensional like you
know universes out there
and everything else i already discussed
trust me people and there's no jobs
because everything's automated
and you all you don't need much money to
job the jobs would be in the metaverse
though oh did you see that they hired uh
casino hosts in the metaverse yeah yeah
so there's people in other countries
that
get paid more than their living wage
to be uh virtual yeah i think another
problem though is that the metaverse is
so egalitarian in terms of people that
can work because anyone around the world
can work there i think that the pay is
going to be very low and i don't think
it's going to attract you know anything
right any skilled workers yeah i think
it was ghana that people were making now
like four or five hundred dollars a
month so it's four times the minimum
wage
uh on axi infinity which is great for a
lot of developing countries i presumably
unless i'm missing some things but i
don't think that's going to be you're
not going to be able to make 90 000 a
year at these you know low-level jobs in
the metaverse and maybe there are jobs
in the matter i just don't know enough
about it but regardless people are going
to be waking up putting in their contact
lenses and staying at home you know 15
hours a day and it's going to have a lot
of negative consequences for society
it's just wild to think about because if
it's really that good would you want the
real world anyway no you won't no it's
literally like the matrix right oh most
people will choose
the red no the blue pill
most people will be choosing the blue
pill in 20 years i mean we're not there
yet the men of verse is still like kind
of a grainy two-dimensional thing right
but there's no question that we will
have contact lenses and be living in a
metaverse in 20 years i mean there's
just no question i mean imagine this
crim yeah you you wanted to buy
um that car from whovi
oh yeah or just imagine you you didn't
have your gt yet right yeah why would
you spend
200 and however much grand on a car in
real life when you can buy it on the
metaverse for 20 grand and it's the same
experience
to drive the car to display the car
exactly the same thing
it might be a very similar experience so
why why would anybody like ready player
one yeah exactly yeah so why would you
choose the real-life car when you get
the exact same i don't know i don't know
out of the the metaverse i don't know i
think it's gonna it's gonna be used in
the beginning for flexing of people to
show not just how beginning you know i
mean right there's no
universe you put whatever name in front
of anyone where people won't be flexing
their money yeah yeah they'll be halves
and half knots in the metaverse too so
why don't you buy land in the metaverse
why not just take well again because i
equate it to crypto i think that
that
the values have gone up so much that
there could be a little bit of a
reckoning um but again and again i don't
know which which metaverse i think
that's the most there's no question yeah
there is no question that land in
whatever metaverse ends up being like
one of the more dominant metaverses is
going to be an excellent investment i
mean there will be millions and millions
of dollars for good pieces of land and
for houses no question
it's interesting one of my first clients
his name was john jacobs and he held the
record and i remember looking looking
him up when i'm trying to like research
who he was he held the record for the
most expensive virtual item ever sold in
2010. it was in this uh they called it
it was a game what was it uh it was like
this entropia universe oh he had the
disco yeah
he had no he had an asteroid yeah
it was a disco something like that yeah
you visit his ass yes yeah so he
sold this for 630 000 in 2010
back then and it was a disco he was
making two hundred thousand dollars a
year from this and people would pay to
gain access to his disco in the game and
he owned well that's the same thing
what's going on in like other you know
meta versus right now you're gonna be
making a fortune if you own land and you
build a casino or you build like you
know a a destination and you rent it out
yeah or people and people will be
spending most of their money and in 20
years 10 to 20 years people will be
spending most of their money in the
metaverse are you worried about the
impact on real estate for like let's say
for you 20 years from now if you're
thinking ahead how does this impact your
business i think that the
listen there's so many things that that
are hard to kind of figure out about
this but if i had to guess in in
in 20 years i'd say that a lot
of people will not need as much from
where they're living i mean i think
first of all you're not going to
probably see many shopping centers in a
lot of and i don't really think you're
going to be seeing
um you know commercial spaces like
you've got these big towers you know
with thousands of people coming into
work
and those will
have to be converted to
residential housing at some point
because i mean who
we're not going to be having a bunch of
people going to work in 20 years
um
and i think that you'll have a lot of
people that could
probably live in you know a 600 square
foot
you know
condo without a view and there'll be
technology in 20 years where you can put
a you know a little window on a wall you
know like like a samsung frame tv but
imagine it you know 50 000 times better
and it'll look like a view and it'll
move when you move and it'll be whatever
view you want so i think you could
probably turn
a really crappy dark apartment into a
gorgeous little you know apartment just
from these little fake windows uh and
and you'll have natural light i mean
you'll probably be able to have
sun roofs you know for in 20 years
you'll be able to buy a sunroof just put
it onto a dark ceiling and it'll look
like the sun and the sun will move and
you won't be able to tell if that
sunroof or whatever you want to call it
sunlight
is uh is real or not in 20 years you'll
have no way of knowing and it will be at
night and you can black it out when you
don't want to wake up i mean it's so i i
think that technology is going to have a
huge impact on on real estate that's
crazy but i will also say that people
will be living at home more and staying
at home more so you know you've got
i guess different you know pulls and
pushes
yeah i was going to say i think we
should talk about
the the netflix show i mean
there's a lot of that's so boring let's
i always talk about the netflix show
this stuff is more fun
let's see if there's cause since jack's
not able to make it he has a few
questions for you i just want to see if
there's anything
in here that that has to do with the
show that we could get out of the way on
this sure um i'm not saying i won't talk
about it i'm just saying it's boring
yeah i'm just saying i think maybe yeah
people would like to hear a little bit
okay fine yeah um i like them so jack
wants to know
why do you continue to sell real estate
when at this point you could leverage
the show and you could leverage your
audience to make money in other ways
that don't involve that maybe you could
make way more i haven't leveraged the
show honestly to make one dollar uh
anywhere else besides buying and selling
property i have not
used my instagram
uh or anything else to make literally
one dollar that's
what jason told me that i was like i
thought for sure
collaboration i'm like jason why aren't
you doing sponsors on instagram i'm not
saying i i i'm not saying i wouldn't do
like a quality
you know sponsor i just i don't know
it's not i'm not trying to like you know
sell or make twenty thousand dollars on
a post to like sell a razor and be like
oh my favorite you know beard trick i
think you're under i'm not saying you
have to by the way
i've got you but not you know you gotta
pay me what did we do for the for the we
did oh manscaped we did a sponsorship
with manchester united oh i was
listening you talked to me in a year and
i'll have done like 20 spots i'm just
saying i have not yet it's not really my
thing yet you you went through the same
progression that i did in the very
beginning uh the first i think three
months on youtube i didn't put any ads
in my videos because i'm like oh you
know what i don't need the money i don't
want to be that guy i don't want to be
that guy's putting ads in this this is
silly
uh and then i was just like well if it's
going to help the algorithm i'm going to
put an ad in the video and it helped the
algorithm and then they started making
some money i was like well if one ad
helps the algorithm what's two ads it
helped the algorithm even more and then
i was actually making a decent amount of
money but i said no to sponsors for
three years i didn't do a single sponsor
because i was thinking i'm making so
much money from ad revenue i don't need
to take sponsors you only need to take
sponsors if
i can't imagine you saying i'm making so
much money from ad revenue i don't need
yeah that's how i felt because only the
people who were doing sponsored they
made no money in ad revenue so it's like
okay they have to do sponsors but i
don't have to do that
uh and then it's it started and started
trickling in i think it was simply safe
uh was the one of the first sponsors on
the channel the home security system oh
that you know what i remember seeing
that and it was such a natural
integration because
you set it up in your house right yeah
so that to me makes sense like i would
do like a collaboration with like you
know sonos or something like that like
some type of real estate listen we're
going down the rabbit hole here just
listen to this okay yeah everyone is
telling me you're going to make more
money from sponsorships than you will
from ad revenue it's like i didn't
believe them well sure enough a year
later more money from sponsors way more
money from sports i am not going to be
making more money from guess what we had
a sponsor the other day actually the
post today our company where
uh technically we are both
lords so you have to refer to both of us
as a lord
because we bought land and where is it
scotland
ireland they sponsored a video so far
fifty dollars
so uh jason
i'm not calling you guys
but you you don't own land yeah you are
are you a lord
i'm lord
seriously they send you a certificate
but they're just saying oh well if they
send you a certificate then you're then
it's literally they sponsored the video
but my point is we've gone from there
like i'm not doing it as sponsors to now
like you could be a lord for like thirty
dollars well we'll do it we'll do a
podcast every year now i'll update you
on that but i'm telling you i think for
very minimal work you'd be able to clear
an extra probably three million bucks a
year with with
very little work yeah listen i would i
would do that yeah i just have not
gotten off my ass and you know thought
about it yet maybe i need to hire
someone that can do that but i think
there is a way to leverage this and make
more money than you're expecting and
maybe that might uh shift your i don't
want to say it might because i'm always
going to work in real estate
but i'm more than happy to do you know
extracurricular things i mean it's worth
it to pursue why didn't you just called
it extra career yeah some extraction why
didn't you pursue the route that i saw
brett take which is creating a program
and i think just the the time i mean my
brother spent like a year and a half on
that
uh i and i mean i was i could never have
spent
a tenth as much time as he spent
creating that class so i think for that
reason i bet in a weekend though if you
well i guess probably about a week i bet
you could spend five days with somebody
planning it out and a weekend going over
it just
literally talking about you and like 18
months every day you need to well but
that's our personality though is just to
be we just you know our personality is
not debating something so i'll tell you
when when i did the first real estate
agent program i spent a year working on
that thing and it was horrible i
scripted everything out yeah i hated it
oh you were there for that yeah and i it
bombed it just like nobody was
interested in it i just didn't not that
many people were interested in that my
youtube program on the other hand i
spent 30 days on that
nothing was scripted and i just had
bullet points in front of a white board
and i was just you know talking and
making the points
i'm like someone who just wants to just
you know
go over script everything out i mean
plus the other thing too is my brother
has the best one out there like i'll i
would never want to have another one
like i will never do one as good as he
did
no matter how much time i spend so
i don't know i mean but then you would
have something that would compete with
him maybe i wouldn't want to compete
with him but regardless i i've watched
it okay i will never
ever do something that good we were
talking a while ago doing a mentorship
where you would basically have people
pay you you know however much just for
your thoughts on their real estate
situations or or if something is goodbye
or how to negotiate or something like
that i thought it made it really well i
don't know i just it's that's not
totally my personality you know i'm just
more like
uh
yeah i don't know
i don't think i would be doing that i
just think my personality is more just
like focus on buying and selling real
estate got it and just you know i'm not
trying to add a ton more to my plate
right now i say that as i open up a
vegas office and maybe get a third show
but
um
whatever yeah do you think there's any
points that you're just gonna retire and
take it easy or or you know scale back a
little bit from what you're doing
you know probably not because i think
that
if i
every time i think about where i want to
be before i retire that if i once i get
there and i've done that many times
i just want you know to be working
harder and expand more and be more
successful and i also love what i'm
doing i think i'd be bored off my ass if
i retired so i don't i think i could
slow down and travel more you know i
already am
but
i just don't think i ever want to unplug
in what i'm doing what if
at some point the shows will you know
stop yeah and i'll have more time yeah
have you been surprised at the success
of the show yeah
obviously what was your reaction when it
first came out because i remember i
don't know if we could we could talk
about this but in the very beginning i
think that when you saw the first
episode or two i think you weren't you
disappointed that it wasn't more real
estate i think i think in the beginning
you would you had told you had told them
it's like i wanted to be like 80 real
estate yeah i think and then they had
their direction and wasn't there some
classes
well no it wasn't a clash i mean at the
end of the day they were completely
right we have a show that was 50 times
more successful than any show that i
would have ever you know wanted
um but yeah i thought you know i was so
concerned about my brand and i was i'm
just you know barely kind of controlling
and
um and i like to manage you know
everything so for me to delegate
anything was very difficult like in
season one but once i saw that it was
good
um i you know i chilled out yeah and i
stopped you know i just
let production do their thing right um
but yeah i mean at the end at the
beginning
i wanted this show to be real estate
focused but honestly it would have
probably been a shitty show yeah how did
the show even come up to begin with did
did they approach you
in the beginning yeah so we've been
approached by you know different agents
and producers and
adam devillo our current producer and
skyler i think one of them reached out
and you know even we were not interested
when they reached out but then they like
pushed to get a meeting and we hadn't
taken a meeting in like six months or a
year
um
and so we took a meeting and then we you
know we kind of warmed up to it i think
the other agents were you know excited
about it as well
one thing led to another you know before
you know we were filming a pilot
yeah
but yeah at first i wasn't
i was yeah i thought it was more risk
than reward what was the why did you
agree to it then if you felt like
there's two i just i just turned i just
started getting more excited about it
you know i just kind of we had a it was
a good producer
i thought it was going to be fun you
know i'm definitely one of those people
that likes to take risks and you know
you know yolo type of thing so that was
probably it
do you get uh maybe fans of the show
that come to the office and try to like
look through the window every two
minutes yeah really yeah i can almost
not even work in the office that's crazy
when it the show first came out i would
be the only one in the office at 9 00
p.m and this is like the very first and
uh i could it was difficult because they
would they would come in and they'd peer
in and i would be the only one in there
and some of them would
like knock and i'd be like like the
answer or they'd go there and try to
open the door yeah they still do
what if it was open
you have to make sure it's launched wow
you should yeah you should it's insane
now it's it's every i would say
40 to 50
people come by during the day i mean
it's it's every couple minutes and but
usually they just jump out of their car
take a photo in front and you know we
just continue working but a lot of times
they will knock and listen at the end of
the day i mean i think you have a
responsibility because these are you
know your fans and
and you they are really happy when you
go out and take a photo with them so how
do you balance i try to do that going
and taking pictures with people while
still working because i know how
distracting it's it's difficult i mean i
i try to remind myself
that it's 10 seconds of my life and it
makes them really happy so from that
utilitarian perspective i really you
know i feel like it's an obligation to
do that
um but you know i mean sometimes you're
you know you're trying to get work done
so it's it's a hard balance because it's
certainly with season four it's gotten
more worse i guess i want to say how
surprised are people to show up to the
office and see someone on the show in
the office are they expecting like
happy and surprised i mean it's usually
me i'm there a lot so it's me a lot
um no they get pretty excited yeah for
sure i did that with pawn stars i was so
excited
i did that too yeah
wait are they actually there no no no no
nobody was there when i don't know no uh
sorry no one was there oh yeah so
i thought like for
[Music]
out of there anymore i mean they do but
it's like they put everything at such a
high price yeah because it's a novelty
to be exactly going there like look you
know where i bought this yeah exactly
but i mean everything's like fifty
percent more than it should be yeah do
you watch the show at all have you seen
selling sensations oh i watch it
everyone watches they send us a screen
yeah we have to because we have press
they asked us about it
um so they sent us a screener usually
just a few days before it airs and then
i watch it got it yeah i mean i'm
not someone who watches reality tv i
outside of watching selling sunset of
course i've watched every season of
selling sunset is there anything in the
show where you think it wasn't portrayed
the right way or you've seen something
and being like oh that was taken out of
course
they made me look jealous of simu coming
in
so that was a little yeah
i had so i i have not seen any i think i
saw some of season one but i scroll and
i just find myself and i'm like
that's what i've done but season
four right this last one it was on an
airplane and i watched the entire thing
the first time from start to finish all
in one goes really good but yeah but the
semi thing how did that
take
yeah bunny had some fun in the
production bay with that but
i mean listen whatever
so you so was it taken out of context or
or not i mean i was not yes i was not i
mean i i think that guy is awesome but i
was not uh
that i don't think that's exactly how it
went down
okay
oh man if you weren't doing real estate
what would you be doing
uh
maybe i would you know it'd be probably
fun to own like a a card shop maybe in
like
buy and sell like vintage baseball and
football cards that's or artwork i do
like like collecting art and like uh
sports cards so something in there would
be fun what if you were starting over
and you're broke today
no i mean i take that as the same
question
right um what i would well i would do if
i couldn't do real estate i mean no if
you could if you could do real estate
like let's say you have zero dollars and
you're starting out somebody comes to
you is like what can i do give me like
three steps i i i mean uh okay asking me
what i would do i mean i would do real
estate i mean basically that is what i
did when i had that decision you know uh
10 years ago i would make the decision
every day
uh you're asking me what they said
specifically yeah i would do what i did
i would join a a brokerage where you
partner with like a really good agent i
mean that's
i think more forget about what brokerage
really i think you need to partner and
this i think equates to not just being
successful in real estate but anything
um as a lawyer i worked under an amazing
dan petrocelli he was an amazing lawyer
and i think that whatever you're doing
but let's let's go with real estate you
partner with a really good person too
and you don't focus on the money you
don't focus on the commission i mean you
know
how much commission we were giving up to
our real estate partner then to coldwell
banker i mean we weren't making i think
i was making 27 cents for every dollar i
made in commission but i was focusing on
experience learning you know building a
um a client base so that's what i would
do i just focus on
learning a lot of people
focus on like this get rich quick
mentality and they and they really just
think about oh how can i make quick
money and i think crypto has a lot to do
with and i think you know
seeing other people make money so
quickly and in the metaverse or in a
crypto punk or in you know bitcoin
whatever
so they don't have this mentality of
like a 10-year plan
uh and i think that's what you know we
need to get back to it's like where do
you want to be in 10 years i know
to say it cliche
but spend
in like the next three to five years
building a you know a client base you
know learning becoming an expert i mean
what happened to actually just being
great at what you do
that's how i got successful just by
working hard and becoming you know
excellent at what i do
um and i think people just need to focus
on like the old school mentality yeah so
if there's one thing out there that you
haven't accomplished yet that you still
want what would it be
i don't even know
you got it i feel accomplished yeah i i
don't feel like there's i don't have any
yearning for any type of you know
uh
extra success
but i would have answered that this
question 10 years ago the same i don't
really like uh
not like a
goal-oriented person in that way i just
like to just keep pushing forward and
whatever happens happens but i don't
have like oh i need to
make this or do this or own this or
whatever i just
just keep moving forward got it
what questions do you have for us
ask away how much money has the iced tea
coffee hour with graham and jack made
uh with with sponsorships yeah i do i
don't know to be honest with you we've
had some good months uh
under a million i think
i don't know
okay i have no idea jack does all the
accounting on that i have i have no clue
you might want to you might want to find
out
okay let me see what the questions i
have okay can you keep up the same
amount of content and same quality of
content that you're pushing out now or
are you going to burn out i'm br i've
i've been saying this for a while now i
remember asking you i think it was like
two years ago i'm like jason i'm kind of
burnt out i can't do any more uh and you
told me to scale back and i'm like uh
maybe you know maybe at the end of the
year and then i just i pushed through
and i just told you it's a marathon yeah
i said you gotta you know have you got
to get through at least five more years
so
yeah so alex is starting to edit my
videos and after this oh i know what i
told you i told you to start delegating
and bringing on google we're still out
we're still working on that yeah yes you
had a problem with that even back then
oh god he didn't want to do anything
with it he didn't want anyone to help
him yeah that's how it's impossible
that's how i used to be so i get it yeah
and we're but you have to start
delegating yeah i actually i called
jason jason was the one who really
convinced me to hire jack in the very
beginning really yeah yeah
because i was thinking oh you know i
could do it myself
really and jack came on and
when i was not anything jack jack was
doing such a good job but it was just
like but i was there too i mean i had a
really hard time hiring my first
assistant and then afterwards i was like
oh my god how did i ever live without an
assistant i bet you you don't even know
how you could do it you couldn't go back
no i couldn't yeah well not with all the
content
yeah yeah but now it's a it's almost i'm
fearful of that because you can't go
back so once you do that then that's
like a permanent little brick that you
put up there and it's always gonna stay
there so you can't take that away are
you calling me a brick yeah
just break it just doesn't it just
doesn't leave
uh
but no the answer is i've constantly
felt like i burnt out constantly um and
i get like usually about two days a week
where i'm just like i'm i'm over it but
the other five days are fine
so it's like sometimes it's challenging
but i push through like my goal you
really feel like that what like you
don't know that no because that's
exactly how i feel oh yeah everybody but
he feels it like six days a week
but my thought was like how does graham
work so much and never feel burnt out i
didn't know you know all the time burned
out and then yeah and then like then i
get that one to two days where it's like
it's like a hump and you know yeah work
and then um you get that one day on the
weekend or something where you know oh
you have dinner with your girlfriend and
then you do netflix and then like my
whole mind resets like i didn't know you
actually feel boring yeah oh yeah for
three years probably two or three years
i felt like that and you just have to
monitor your happiness if you drop below
like i look back like you know you got
to look back every six months and just
be like you know what's my happiness
like if you're ever below a seven yeah
but i feel like there's also a time to
like keep pushing and grinding and like
you know so what if you're not like a 10
happiness no i'm just saying you got to
make sure you're like at least a seven
you know my whole life i've always made
sure that i'm at least you know seven i
don't know the last year
just feels like a total blur like i have
no idea like you asked me what i did
last night or yeah i'd have no i have no
clue it's i really don't know so like
burger fuku burger yeah i but i forgot
because there's there's just it's but
you're also building focused you're
building a uh
you know
i think you're building your finances to
the point where you're protecting
yourself for life so there's a value
there
you know
that you have to just push through right
so you do it you have to make some
sacrifices if you were
i mean i think i guess what i'm saying
is probably more relevant to somebody
who's you know not making as much
because i think when you're making
enough to where you're really securing
your financial future you got to just
push through right it's difficult for me
because originally that was hiring alex
and having alex edit my videos so he's
been doing that uh but it's odd because
sometimes for me editing is my way to
reset my mind
and because now it frees up like let's
say five hours uh so 15 hours a week now
it's kind of freed up for me but
my editing was a way to like kind of
like just zone out for a little bit get
a video done and then i'm refreshed but
now it's like when i finish a video so
planning and filming i hand it off to
alex and i'm like i gotta go back to
planning so i don't have that like five
hours right so i can't increase my own
productivity because i get back to
planning and i'm like everything's crap
out there there's there's nothing to
talk about versus before where i would
edit i'd have that five hours to zone
out and then come back refreshed
maybe i gotta find something i'm gonna
edit a little bit more i don't know yeah
but i mean i'm just i have you know i
delegate the hell out of out of things
that i don't i'm not needed for i mean i
think that's the trick to anyone
becoming successful do you think graham
graham has this idea and and i don't
have an opinion on it just so you know
graham has this idea jack has a
different idea graham thinks that
he can't really delegate like script
writing
um because that's kind of the videos are
him right
um and then jack thinks
oh i don't know what jack thinks i don't
want to speak for him but some people do
say that he can delegate scriptwriting i
think that at some point
i don't think it's black and white but i
think at some point you should obviously
hire someone to do scripting and you can
you can review it or not use it but i
think the natural course of where you're
going is going to have to be people
you know doing more scripting and you
doing less scripting i don't think it
has to be all or nothing it's just tough
because once i make a change i i won't
go back so i know don't you get ideas
from people so that's like you know
ideas from the comments or the the best
ideas yeah so that's comments scripting
in a way i mean it's just it's a it's a
you know
a gray area in terms of a it's not black
and white but i would say that's
scripting getting ideas getting comments
getting things to talk about and then
the next step would just be someone
creating bullet points for you and you
review the bullet points and you
highlight the ones you like and you
script from there but i mean so it's a
it's a progress but i definitely think
you have to start delegating that to
some extent sure
yeah i was thinking i i told uh i think
i told both of you by the end of the
year i wanted to go down to two videos
and now i'm at the end of the year i
still wanna once if i go down to two
it's forever gonna be two so yeah i
can't do it yeah we've been we've been
grinding is that a financial hit if you
go down to two because it's possible
maybe so jack says i would make more
because by doing two i could dedicate
the extra time to finding sponsors and
have like a 100 fill rate so every video
would have a sponsor in it whereas right
now it'd be one in three oh then i would
as a sponsor i would do less work and
and and get more money for less work
but then it's like then every video is
sponsored and then i don't think that
matters i don't think it matters that
much but
i don't think but i could do three
videos that we can have them all
sponsored too yeah but you gotta but
you're not doing that yeah i know yeah i
think you maybe go down to two and get
them all sponsored and you make just as
much money and for less work
i don't know yeah i just i mean listen i
don't know i'm taking this on youtube so
i'm just now yeah so i just moved the
goal post a little bit so it was the end
of the year and now i'm thinking my
birthday in april then i could if i
could keep three videos up just until
april
well i mean you gotta it's a marathon i
i've always told you that i know same
with real estate i mean i i'll be honest
i don't hustle like as hard as i used to
like i will
you know delegate a million i used to do
a 700 000 condo
you know and now i'll delegate you know
a million two million dollar house to
other agents
um because i mean quality of life
matters
you know so you gotta
so
it's not i mean i'm not gonna delegate a
five million dollar house and i'm still
going to be totally involved because
that's just my personality but yeah i
mean i just delegate more and more as i
you know as you grow some other advice
that you have
i mean i don't know if i'm great at
advice outside of real estate really
yeah there's got to be something it's
not really to consider it a business
business financial
whatever it might be i mean i enjoy
something i enjoy investing i mean i
enjoy financial investing um
but i think i have a you know a very
biased take towards it because i invest
a lot of that in real estate but i enjoy
stocks you know i enjoy like little
quick plays in the stock market
but at the end of the day i'm smart
enough to know that
that
nobody really knows about stock market
cryptocurrencies metaverse i mean it's
just it's just gambling
so
uh i don't i wouldn't want to pretend to
advise about it sure what about advice
for alex myself any questions you have
for us it's your chance to flip the
script here oh i don't i mean i'm not
i'm also not good i would never i would
suck over doing your job okay yeah
what did you mean yeah what did you
think when uh
when graham was growing on youtube did
you see that inevitably he would have to
leave the brokerage no so i mean it's a
good question because i when graham
first told me he was going to start
doing youtube i i rolled yeah you know
jason had a talk and he said if if you
if you just stick with this
i guarantee you'll make like 700 grand
in real estate in real estate in the
next like you know two years all you got
to do is just stick with this really
yeah no i was not a fan of him doing
youtube i'm like bro come on
and then he wanted to do it out of the
office i'm like no i cannot remember
that yeah he told us he would uh
he would wait till everybody was out of
the office and he would film yeah
exactly he would i was so embarrassed
because one time i think it was davina i
was i was in the upstairs zombie like
something and i heard the door like baby
beep and i was i sat there with like the
phone up and i was so embarrassed that
the dina came in
and i was like do i say i'm here do i
spook her
so yeah that's what he would do he'd be
upstairs doing youtube yeah so you were
convincing him to
i didn't i mean listen i mean that's on
me but because yeah i was saying no
focus on real estate
but i mean come on you know you know
many people get into youtube and aren't
successful yeah i mean probably 98 of
people
it was it was interesting it was just a
feeling i had i i couldn't explain it i
and i told jason this i'm like i just i
i feel like this is what i have to do
i think you have some unique qualities
that are really good on youtube like
you're you're really smart but you're
able to
relay that to people whereas i think a
lot of really smart people are not like
i would be terrible on youtube i don't
know how to like
connect to that audience yeah so i think
that you have that relatability
of course i mean how would i know that
at the beginning yeah plus now i've lost
a great he was one of my top agents and
now i've lost a great agent but you know
what you know how much money i make off
of graham now yeah
but you know what you did help me in in
the beginning uh and i don't think i've
ever expressed this in the very
beginning you were really upset at me
for swearing in my videos and
yeah that was yeah we called you out
yeah yeah uh because in the in the first
few because i saw youtube as like no
like no one was was adding any
personality to find the finance videos
didn't exist and the people that did the
videos were like in front of a white
board and they'd like you know write
stuff out so i came in you're making fun
of jeremy right now well yeah jeremy no
this is before even jeremy oh for jeremy
but jeremy had the white board too but
uh no one came in with the personality
of like swearing so it like caught
people off guard and so when i would say
the f word or like you know the answer
or whatever in a video
everybody was like oh this is so
refreshing it's like some they could
they could relate to that yeah uh
because it was more on their level just
like you know just a budge who's messing
around talking about personal finance um
but then you came to me and said you did
not want me swearing um
because it was a reflection it was a
reflection on the oppenheim group and in
the beginning i'm like this is it then
you know
because then i felt like i was your
personality i'm not given my full
personality and then i have to like
censor myself on youtube
and it turned out to be the best
decision that i didn't swear because
shortly after that youtube went through
the adpocalypse like i think it was like
that year
where they demonetized any content with
swearing and so because i had been built
up this audience without swearing in a
really clean image it worked in my favor
okay so in the beginning in the
beginning it was something i was like oh
so in a way he made you money
yeah yeah yeah oh absolutely and now we
don't swear at all like you you've said
a few naughty words here we edit those
out yeah because
i watched one video maybe i picked the
wrong one yeah but i'm like you know
what i've never watched any grams videos
i got to check one out and i just
watched like a two two minutes of one
video and i heard all this cussing i'm
like bro you got to knock that off i was
freaked out i'm like is that in every
video was he recording in the office no
oh okay
um but uh no in the the office videos i
didn't yeah i think he at first said
that he's like what if i don't swear
when i'm in the office
but i mean i wasn't trying to like you
know manage your your content but i
didn't he was an agent of the oppenheim
group and i just you know i'm very
protective of the broker yeah so i put
i'm thinking of it if i if i were in
your position i'd do the exact same
thing i'd be like this isn't a good
reflection like if jack started jack
started a channel but if he's out there
just like cursing and doing whatever i
wouldn't want that because that would
come back on me if if something were to
happen
so i get it i think i mean listen i had
such a disconnect from when you were
like you were like oh
outgoing and like energetic and like
cussing and that was not very much my
personality so i was like holy
[Laughter]
the turns of table now you're the one
who said some naughty words
yeah i probably care less now than i
than i used to because i mean at some
point you just have to stop you know
carrying these scratches
to the to the story
yeah i'm always curious now if i swore
in the videos how that would impact them
today if people would find it
now i think the audience also depends on
what words you're talking about and it
depends on your sponsors i mean you just
got to be careful with your sponsors and
that's and that's true too yeah i mean
people are so [ __ ] sensitive no
offense
but they really are i mean it's just
unbelievable how many haters are out
there and how sensitive actually i don't
even think it's real sensitivity i just
think that there are people that just
love getting worked up like i don't know
how if they're just super bored or not
happy or whatever it is
yeah i feel like that's been social
media for a while now just people will
get worked up i don't read i don't read
comments i don't do twitter i don't i
just can't i just can't deal i cannot
deal with like all of the
over sensitivity and hating out there i
i just can't so i don't deal with it you
know i don't even want to i can't even
deal with news i mean
every news analogy there's so left or so
right i mean you can't watch i just i'm
so over all of it i just i'm and i'm way
happier but the thing is that gets views
so like i've noticed even on youtube
well that's what all that's what all
content is about his views the drama
people love that so i posted a video on
the the island boys i don't know if
you're familiar with them okay well they
they walked out of somebody else's
podcast because they were given
financial advice and they did not want
to hear it so i did a video analyzing
their finances and why they walked off
of the podcast and why that was a good
or bad decision and that video on that
drama got like five times of views as
anything else because it was like
and i'm on selling sunset i mean i i i i
yeah exactly
right
i mean it does yeah it does well because
of the drama i'm sure um but i'm just in
general
i just think you know we're so geared
towards i mean
everything has to be
a fire or a tornado or a car accident or
you know i mean everything is so
negative because it's clickbait i mean
everything has been reduced now to what
gets people's quarter you know what what
raises people's people's cortisol levels
that is literally what
you know most things are right now and
it's just yeah i i don't want to engage
you see that movie with uh leonardo
dicaprio yeah yeah it reminds me of that
when they're like well we see the uh the
metrics on yes and we got a spike right
here but then the die down so it's it's
we can't push this anymore yeah but it's
true but that's that's what happens with
youtube i mean that's why i almost want
like every i was almost like like a
public news channel i mean isn't it
isn't it like pbs or something like that
boring though i know but that's what
news should be new should not be like
click bait you know
and then and then super biased towards
one political party so see that doesn't
bother me what bothers me is i guess the
cancel culture
if something happens people will latch
onto it and then just go crazy and then
everyone people really enjoy
you know
people falling i i mean it's just i
don't know if it's just like a human
nature thing i think it's a human nature
yeah i don't think there's anything new
i mean i was so paranoid it was just
easier now to like oh yeah to get
involved in that yeah and that and you
can't do that but then you get a
community behind you who all believe the
same thing so you're part of this big
you know group of people who all want to
like hate on this one person and you
feel better as a result i think people
feel better yeah
about it too yeah there's a lot of just
unhappy people out there i don't know
what's going on but listen i think you
know there's you can avoid it like i
genuinely just avoid it i mean i don't
read news don't watch news don't
engage in comments or read comments or
really you ever curious i'm just reading
a comment because i you i also just
genuinely
uh
don't really care you know so i have
like a
you know i i think that's
i got lucky in that respect i'm just not
particularly sensitive to what other
people think and then maybe that's a bad
thing i don't really care
see i don't care yeah um but yeah i
think i'm just kind of immune you know
it doesn't it's like some
article comes out
it just doesn't bother me i'm not very
sensitive i'm happy i know who i am i
know you know my relationship with my
family and my friends it's really all
that affects me
but do you think there there could be
something where you have to speak up if
if something impacts the people yeah now
i'm worried it's like anything you do or
anybody does then
is back on the oppenheim group in such a
good way
you don't even need to do anything right
i mean quite honestly right really yeah
you just if you're a public figure i
mean you know you're you're a target
yeah so yeah i have not had to but you
know i mean i would definitely speak up
if if something if someone got wronged
yeah if anyone on the team got wronged
does that worry you though that that
it's just like so many eyeballs on the
opponent group and just i guess people
not working with you as a result or like
i don't like spend my day worrying about
this stuff you know i mean i just i just
do i just act up you know in a manner
that that i'm that's fine you know that
i should act but yeah i mean listen any
time you're in the public eye
and i think it's particularly sensitive
now um and with cancel culture and you
know
everything else and just a lot of
political correctness
i think that any little thing could get
blown out of proportion so i mean i've
always encouraged everyone i mean i've
told
every agent you know on the cast as well
as off the cast
for years now just you know you need to
always act as though they're you're
being videoed always act as though
you're being recorded in video and quite
honestly
you know i mean i think people should
you first of all you are i mean almost
all of us now but you know i i it's been
nice because no one is really no one's
an idiot no one does stupid stuff that
i'm aware of so you know
nothing's really uh happened but i think
you just have to be extra careful
because nobody loves more than than you
know a public figure screwing up
i mean i was so paranoid when you hired
me i never expected to be on camera
first of all ever because graham hired
me as an assistant but i was so paranoid
that
i don't know what i i didn't even post
bad things but i deleted my whole
facebook when i moved out to vegas i
made another oh yeah but just because i
was paranoid like because that's the
culture that we're in oh i mean
yeah you have to
when i went i was becoming a public
figure i mean i've never there's nothing
in my past that i'm that would be
concerning but they definitely go
through i mean i've never had to delete
a post or anything i've ever said
um
but yeah i mean they
anything that you've ever done wrong
would it would come out i mean any
acquaintance or friend would sell you
out you know i guess not a friend but i
mean if you'd ever done anything wrong
you cannot be a public figure i mean
it's just it's unbelievable because they
would look at everything yeah
i wonder if there's a service that you
could pay that would look through
anything in the past and well actually i
think netflix goes through and make sure
that you're yeah because
you can imagine if they build a show and
someone on that show you know has done
something yeah and then it comes out
later then the show has to get cancelled
so no they do their research to make
sure that there's no i mean you could
never do everything but
yeah i mean at this point if anyone on
our show had probably ever done anything
it would probably be out yeah you got to
knock on wood let's let's not jinx
anything
you don't knock on wood no i don't you
don't no i don't believe in this okay
i'll do it though there oh there we go
he saved it cool uh is there anything
else i think or no i think that's good i
think that was good uh anything else
that you want to say no no i'm good it's
just good to check out your house it is
yeah first time singing what do you
think of the house i love it man yeah it
makes me want to buy something in vegas
i think you should yeah i might i mean i
wish i was not like a year ago but no
this this i like this community yeah
yeah you're still building it you just
sell me this at the same price you you
know you paid for it plus bitcoin
plus a bitcoin
i think you should buy up here
i i mean i like this gated community and
i this is like the right size house for
me cool yeah well i'll think about it
all right i'll convince you so all right
thanks so much for
watching to get your free stock down
below in the description when you sign
up for public
did you do that yet it's worth all the
way up to a thousand dollars i'm not
worth my time no you just
just say yes
yes it sounds good okay there you go
public you can get one too public i'm
available i have not done a collab ever
so all right let's go get him his free
bankroll coffee oh yeah i'll give you
some bakery real coffee okay that's more
interesting yeah available at
bankrollcoffee.com
all the plugs
thanks man that was perfect oh cool guys
thanks
i'm sure i'll get in trouble with
something i said but